e.t is taking a look back at iconic red
carpet moments that
changed the game my egg rental you know
that wasn't available
and how these moments changed red carpet
style forever
it's like putting on that dress and
putting on them pumps made me feel the
most powerful and the most masculine
that i've ever felt
i'm denny directo and joining me for
this fashion rewind
is our panel of style experts celebrity
stylist
ceo and style expert rachel zoe there
are a few moments
in my career where i was actually
brought to tears
comedian jessie wu angelina showed up to
that red carpet and said honey kfc and
popeyes ain't the only place y'all can
get a thigh honey
an e.t style senior producer our very
own marissa runyan
she made red carpet fashion into
something way more than just showing up
and looking pretty
[Music]
we're laughing we're crying we are
tripping over her oscar style
years later i'm talking of course about
jennifer lawrence
the girl we all love for being so
relatable and
always herself who could forget her in
this christian dior
hot couture at the 2013 oscars where she
of course famously
tripped up the stairs going to receive
her oscar for best actress for silver
linings playbook i mean first of all
rachel you actually styled this stunning
look what was going through your mind
when this happened you know there
are a few moments in my career where i
was
actually brought to tears honestly
putting this look together with her
was by far and away a highlight of my
very long styling career but i think you
know
the greatest thing for me and the
greatest reward for a stylist in my
opinion
is when your client looks in the mirror
right before they leave
and they they feel it they know they
look extraordinary and and when
that happens when that magic moment
happens
it's just that's everything and um when
she went
and she just looked like this all i kept
thinking about was like a young grace
kelly like i just
lost my mind with her and she when she
felt honestly
it's weird it didn't even phase me she
looked so beautiful when she fell and
once we all knew she was okay it was
sort of like it was the most elegant
fall i ever saw in my entire life it's
the way she fell
it was like a dove falling out of the
sky so ever
so softly and you know i was like listen
if i'm gonna fall it better be on my way
to collect the oscar honey who else
and in a dress like it's true and can we
talk about that
diamond necklace going down her back i
mean that accident
you put there it's like this fall was
meant to happen just to feature the
necklace
it's also just so relatable obviously
she was nominated for just about every
award for her performance in silver
linings playbook that year
rachel when you have a client that's
nominated for multiple awards in one
year
how do you even begin to plan out all
those looks because i feel like you guys
really knew what she should wear for the
oscars but how did you plan out the rest
of the red carpets
you know it's it's really hard because
you know you can plan as much as you can
plan right but ultimately
as we all know as human beings you plan
what you're gonna wear but how many
times do you change your mind
right um just before i know i do
um and so as a stylist i have to have
many
options for each thing but i will say
when you're going through an award
season
and i've done many of them with several
clients over the years
you really want to create sort of a
build up you know so there is a build up
thought in my mind as a stylist for sure
well you all crushed that i mean
executed beautifully and we're still
talking about it today
but switching gears to another queen of
the red carpet and really the master of
the poker face
someone who keeps us on our toes when it
comes to red carpet fashion
any guesses lady gaga lady gaga
2010 grammys when she rocked this armani
prive
it was the night that she actually won
her first two grammy awards
um i want you guys to take a look and
then jesse let me know what feeling
this book evokes in you because you know
gaga does it up she
really balances that line between
couture and costume what did you make of
this look jesse
this gives me i am not one of y'all okay
i'm not even human baby look it is
giving me mars
venus saturn
from outer space that's what it's giving
me i came from another planet to collect
my awards thank you very much look at me
yes
how you doing that's what it's gonna be
you know i what i love about it too is
that this is one of her first times at
the grammys i mean this is a debut
especially for lady gaga
marissa how do you think gaga's look
kind of changed the way we think about
fashion in general on a red carpet i
mean really she's the ultimate game
changer for me
she made red carpet fashion into
something way more than just showing up
and looking pretty
she shows up and she says this is who i
am that my
art extends beyond my albums beyond my
music videos
i am my art everywhere i go and i mean
i'm clearly a lady gaga fan i've been a
lady gaga fan since the very beginning
and this is why
like you cannot look away from her she
makes everything she does interesting
yeah you know rachel i'm curious to know
is there a line between couture and
costume and is it meant to
cross over is there is it is it a rule
that's meant to be broken
you know it's a really good question and
i think listen
there's there's very conflicting
opinions right because
fashion is the greatest form of
expression it really is i mean
it's how you say who you are without
speaking you walk in and before you open
your mouth
this is what people are looking at this
is what they're thinking about
and i think the thing about gaga the
same way madonna
or cher um i i think i think there
are these game changers on the carpet
who walk in
as marissa said they're artists first
okay and so fashion is an extension of
their art and creativity
and expression and i think the thing
about gaga to note
is how she has you know i think she's
really involved in the sense of
kind of having these sort of moments to
kind of coming on now
in ball gowns and brandon maxwell and
versace
and armani prive and all of these
incredible moments where she comes in
and says okay now i want to be an old
hollywood movie star
now i want to be a lady now i want
people you know
so i i think it's super interesting as
an artist and i think very often you see
this
most at the grammys where they take
risks and they come out and say i don't
care if you like this or not
this is what i'm feeling and this is who
i am right now i'm just being myself
and i'm i'm glad that you like it thank
you well
this next red carpet maven's right leg
was arguably more famous than her during
the 2012 oscars
miss angelina jolie let's remind you
guys of the look it's atelier versace
she became a meme this night at the
oscars uh for this stunning look but
marissa obviously over the years we have
seen angelina
and many many black dresses it's her
go-to color but what sets this moment
apart
oh my gosh well the leg obviously sets
it apart but
you know what it is for me is that she's
an example of how
uh a woman wears a dress the dress
doesn't wear the woman
this for all intents and purposes is a
classic
black ball gown and the thing that sets
it apart is that she is wearing it and
that she is wearing it
and moving and standing and owning it
the way that she is
and it became a meme because not because
people were making fun of her i think
that was something that was really
misconstrued people thought
that they were roasting her because of
the leg no i think it's because we're
all so jealous
that she looks so badass and is owning
this moment
so hardcore in this dress i mean to this
day this is what eight eight
nine years ago still such a solid
enviable red carpet moment
rachel what did you think of this moment
she's so captivating to me
i think um and what i do love about her
to marissa's point
angelina the thing with her i don't
think i've ever seen her wear a dress
that overpowers her
it's like she really picks things that
she
feels compliment who she is
um and never overpower her she's always
about a simple black dress or always
about something that's
that's really just sort of very classic
you know
and i think here this was actually kind
of a lot for her
you know in terms of it being
asymmetrical at being corseted it being
um a ball gown you know we haven't seen
her in a lot of fall counts
but what's so amazing about her is okay
so there's her tattoos and she's got
this classic old hollywood hair and
makeup
and then there's that leg and and a
beautiful leg by the way
but i think what she wanted to say with
that is like
i know i seem really covered up but
guess what i'm not
when you have a slit it's funny you
don't always get the credit for it you
can't see it
and unless you're walking you don't see
the leg or you don't see the slit and i
think what she was saying is like
there's a slit i'm gonna give you
something besides a black dress right
now and this is how i'm doing it and i
think she was just feeling herself in it
honestly you could tell you could even
tell when she was presenting her
her award that night with that red right
leg he could feel the energy in the
audience be like oh
angelina and her leg are here in fact
before the end of the telecast there was
a
twitter handle i don't know if you guys
remember this it was dedicated
to the look with like 14 000 followers
it was called angie's right leg the
account suspended now but jessie
we tried to fight it does not exist
anymore but don't you feel like that
it makes it so much fun for the audience
too to watch
something as so far away as the oscars
red carpet but to feel i don't know
like part of the fun of course totally
angelina showed up to that red carpet
and said honey kfc and popeyes ain't the
only places y'all can get a thigh honey
y'all gonna eat this at night
and we're hungry for more okay i love
her
like y'all are gonna eat me this evening
and then like you said twitter went in
shambles
a whole page was dedicated to her thai
meat you know every
husband meat went trending like it was
all about her thigh
and i love it because angelina she
always keeps it simple
but that evening was like you know keep
it simple but
he got a little bit of that and it just
sent everybody into a frenzy
we almost forgot that angelina was there
with brad pitt because of that look
nobody cared about brad we were just
worried about that thought i might care
about brad
me too
i was all about angelina hertami
her red lipstick she just looked
ravishing
like oh my gosh you know
someone else who gives us plenty to talk
about once they step onto a red carpet
and that is billy porter in 2019 at the
oscars he rocked this custom
christian siriano tuxedo gown it was
such a moment
and he really changed the game i feel
like transforming men's red carpet style
um you know marissa how has billy kind
of changed the game for what we expect
guys to rock on a red carpet you know
this was the oscars
i mean this was like the biggest red
stage there is
and the fact that he showed up in this
gown and owned it and looked
so stunning in it you know people really
stopped and looked and i think they
stopped and looked for all the right
reasons they weren't looking and saying
oh my god why is that man wearing a
dress
they were saying wow why does that man
look so amazing in this dress right now
he was stunning he he really owned the
look and i think this
opens up the door for so much more on
the red carpet the red carpet is the
place where
we see trends begin things shift
cultural norms shift
you know people really seeing um all
different things through fashion and
this opened the door for people like
you know timothy chalamet and harry
styles
jonathan van ness so many men are
wearing more
feminine looks on the carpet not just
dresses but
earrings and jewelry and high heels and
just really beautiful clothing
and i i think that's the thing that
really changed it's not just about
wearing a suit because you're a man it's
wearing something amazing because you're
at the oscars
just a man in a dress it's just a man in
a dress
rachel do you feel like this maybe even
added more pressure for billy over the
years to outdo himself
every time he kind of steps onto a red
carpet
yeah it's it's a hard thing it's sort of
like once
you set that bar that high
you have to keep you have to keep
showing up you know
it's a little like gaga right it's like
if you start off a certain way there's
an expectation like
what are they coming in next what are
they coming in next and i think billy
porter like
listen for me i have i have lived
through so many red carpets
and the truth is is that so often
there's such a letdown of like
how boring and how people are so scared
to to go outside of this safe box
right and i think when people like
lady gaga or billy porter in this case
like when they come on and
do this it's like yes thank you
thank you and also thank you to like so
many
people out there way beyond the red
carpet to say
like it is so okay to express yourself
however you feel
wherever you go you have to own it and i
think part of what made this magical
is how much he owned it he didn't it's
unapologetic
it's like he didn't even think about the
fact that he was
different in walking in a ball gown as a
man it was sort of like
this is incredible and and he just broke
down walls for so many other people
like it's so freaking right and we have
never seen anything like it i think on
the oscars red carpet certainly not from
a man
so jesse when billy porter shows up on
this red carpet the 2019 oscars in this
huge ball gown that's taking over half
the red carpet
your reaction is oh
my god you know it's just like
billy porter being a black gay man
and being on the oscars red carpet
after so many years of acting and
finally having that moment to be there
and for him to have that cinderella
moment for me
it was a cinderella moment i've been in
the business for 30 years
you know there was a period of time when
i first started where you know there was
a
homophobic silencing of every
instinct that i had as a human being on
this planet
and i'm reclaiming my time
maybe someone else who did that throws
an actress who proved that powder blue
isn't
just for fairy tale princesses lupita
nyong'o made a splash in custom prada at
the 2014
oscars taking a risk i think you know
jesse i'll kick it to you first lupita
was a red carpet darling that year
having been nominated for
just about every award leading up to the
oscars which by the way she won
she won her oscar that night but how
would you say this fashion moment to
find
what we've come to expect or maybe not
expect from lupita
but i remember seeing her and thinking
my god she's your queen to be
like i was so proud like oh my god i
touched this look at my good sense
just looking so phenomenal her skin was
moisturized her lips
i were she looks like the belle of the
bar
like my god rachel i'm curious what your
thoughts were on the whole
ensemble head to toe how would you think
of the styling of this
prada honestly this was
absolute perfection and i have to say
that entire season
she was perfection but i remember this
moment and
i have to tell you i was not expecting
this look
i don't think anybody was and i think
that's what made it so extraordinary it
was sort of like
you know she's so badass she's so
amazing and like
she came out with that smile and that
flawless skin just so fresh and dewy and
like this
absolute angel princess um and
with the the headband tiara i like to
think of it as a tiara because
yeah i just dreamed to wear tiaras at
all times um
i mean this is just heaven this is just
classy elegant she cascaded on that
carpet like
i mean look at her she's like a ray of
sunshine
i i just can't love this more honestly
while this gown and maybe the color was
unexpected marissa i know there was a
special significance behind this choice
lupita worked with celebrity stylist
michaela erlinger on this look
so i reached out to her to find out what
exactly makes it truly
special take a listen so the color of
lupita's dress
is famously coined nairobi blue
it was such a beautiful pale shade of
blue and we knew that
in designing her oscars dress and it
being her first oscars we
wanted to include you know some personal
touches
um so that was sort of an homage to her
hometown her home country
this is one of my all-time favorite
looks and holds
such a special place um for me
uh as a stylist this was a look that we
actually worked on
for months um leading up to the oscars
and we started designing it i want to
say back in september or october with
the awards happening around
february or march timing so it was
something that had been in the works
for quite some time and to see it come
to fruition
on oscar's night was something i'll
never forget and i thought that was such
a special moment but
especially because that's when she's
winning her oscar to tie it all back to
her whole life her childhood
her family it made it so much more
special
it wasn't just a pretty dress it was a
pretty dress that really meant something
to her on a deeper level
we were inspired by champagne bubbles
we wanted something you know celebratory
in this gentle blue and
blue who reminds me of my home town
nairobi well next up this
singer's reputation on the red carpet
has been flirty
fearless and folklore fun say that
ten times fast uh taylor swift and
atelier versace at the 2016 grammy
awards
this was quite a departure for taylor
from what we've seen
and i feel like taylor's fashion kind of
has evolved just like her music
plus jessie we know that taylor swift is
the queen
of hidden messages and easter eggs what
do you think she was trying to say
with this look at the grammys in 2016.
she was trying to say listen i'm grown
now
after i leave the grammys i'm going down
to the bar honey okay this
is the a multi-functional outfit it's
it's the bob for me this haircut
the box yes a mean box too because we're
so used to having her
um do the curly big hair so she's like
listen i'm going to go for a little bob
i'm going to put on some i love i love
red lipstick on red carpet i don't know
why
but i have a thing for red lipsticks on
red carpets and she did that and it was
so bold
marissa did you feel like this kind of
signaled that transition to pop music
absolutely i mean that's that's what we
were talking about these artists know
what they're doing she's like i'm going
to change my musical image
so i'm going to change my actual image
she ditched all the things we knew about
her
musically and then she did the same
thing with her personal style
that changed the hair completely she
absolutely looks like a grown up she
started hanging out with different
people she was dating calvin harris at
the time like
she changed up everything when she
changed
her music when her album 1989 as she was
nominated for here at the grammys
that really changed everything for her
now i'll agree with you jessie i do love
a red lip on the carpet and i love that
that is a signature of hers
that she kept as a through line rachel
what do you think of the red lip motif
i do think the one thing we know about
taylor swift is
she really is always sending a message
and whenever she shows up there's a
message
right and whether we ever learn it or
not but
i think here she looked absolutely
stunning it was very powerful though
like i just feel like everything about
it her makeup her bob it's very severe
you know it's very severe for her i
loved it
loved it now i just be myself more
yeah it's just and i have fun with it
well another red carpet hustler whose
glow will go down
in history has become a true fashion
icon over the years
jennifer lopez now it would be an
obvious choice to go with that versace
from the grammys but we wanted to go
with something
a little more unexpected from jlo and
it's this jean batista valley from the
2016
golden globes uh let's start with
marissa what surprised you about this
choice
from jlo this year that year you know
i'm a die-hard j-lo fan and i always
have been and i
stopped what i was doing and i was so
like enthralled in this choice the color
was unexpected for her
the lip like the fact that she wasn't
showing off a ton of skin
but it's still such a jlo look and
that's the thing
we all know jlo's style like we could
recognize it from a mile away
we could see her from the back and know
it's jlo but you have to create
that set of rules for yourself in order
to break them like this
and have it make such an amazing impact
but still feel like you
i think that was the thing that was most
surprising that it wasn't a jlo look but
in every way it still kind of was
it's just inexplicable but it the color
is so perfect the way it fits her
just i'm like overwhelmed by how
beautiful the jewels are on this
it's just probably one of my favorite
looks of all time if you couldn't tell
wake up kick ass repeat wake up kick it
every day
i can hear with j-lo look john batista
volley is a friend of mine for 20 years
he's a master
jennifer lopez i am such a die-hard she
can do no wrong
i don't understand she doesn't get older
she just gets better i can't figure it
out
um she is magically perfect in this
i would have styled her just in like
there's
nothing i would change about this it is
just perfection the
color on her skin the makeup
is do you know how hard it is to get
that makeup and hair right with that
kind of dress it's challenging trust me
and it's the perfect lip with the
glistening eye with the dewy skin
her hair when you have a capelet like
that like over the shoulders
your hair cannot be like down and in
front and taking away
and it just it just perfect and rob and
marielle her stylist who i adore
they just really this was just
perfection oh my god i will never forget
it it was magical
i would like to cut to the 2020 golden
globes because jennifer lopez wore a
valentino gown that
was not universally liked um to say the
least and so i'm curious just you know
were you on board for this look and
do you feel like jayla as you guys put
it can do no wrong
because i don't know i i like j lo when
my favorite jlo on the red carpet is
when she is showing skin i'm sorry
like i just i like i like seeing the
skin i like seeing her back i like
seeing her arms j.lo is well known
for her body she works hard on it
she still looks so youthful i mean she
doesn't look a day over 35.
so i like to see her more exposed but i
get it i get it for those type of events
like you do have to be more
sophisticated so i can appreciate that
all right it's time for a quick
shameless plug rachel please take a
moment to plug and promote whatever
project you'd like
to i just launched my most recent
curation
of curator and i did just launch my own
fragrance
which i'm very excited about there's
four amazing scents that you can choose
from
and that's available on shoprachelso.com
and lots more oh and also i have a
podcast coming out
called works for us that i'm doing with
my husband
uh roger and that's been incredibly fun
i can't busy i love it jesse whoo
plug away i have a podcast called
brownies in the city it's based around
me and my two friends brianna and
diamond we're new to atlanta
so you can literally listen to us or
watch us on youtube as we
take on the city um and be safe of
course
but brian's in the city people look out
for it
love it marissa you too plug et style
for us
you know it e.t style is where you can
find all of the best
and most current shopping deals and
everything that's happening in hollywood
if someone's wearing it we're going to
tell you what it is and how you can find
it and how you can buy it and how you
can wear it and get the look
there's so much there et online slash
style
there you have it our thanks to rachel
zoe jessie wu
and of course marissa runyan it was fun
to talk fashion with y'all thank you so
so much
thank you